men would rather lift weights than go to
therapy well yeah because that makes
them feel powerful
one of the number one things when men
are depressed that i i encourage them to
do is start lifting weights
because you can see the physical changes
in your body and you feel powerful again
you say i can make this change happen
well then i can go make that change
happen
what makes you a voice of authority on
harsh psychology truths
well i've spent a lot of time around
people who are messed up um
no actually i am a licensed
psychotherapist in the united states
nothing i'm going to say is going to be
any healthcare advice but i've been
practicing for years and years
i've worked in correctional settings
i've worked with
inmates in for the death penalty for
severe crimes i've worked in low-income
clinics treating families that no one
else is going to treat i got a lot of
the most severe cases put on my plate
my specialty is post-traumatic stress
disorder and attachment theory and
especially the way those two things
intercede
so when i talk about psychology truths
that's what i'm speaking to is my
personal experience
it just happens to be that lots of the
truths you've learned are also harsh
unfortunately yes yeah the truth can be
harsh when you hear it
it's good to use it but it can be harsh
to burst people's bubble
you are going to use the word attachment
a lot so the way that this came about
you've posted a fantastic twitter thread
which will be linked in the show notes
below and everyone can go and
see 10 times the amount of harsh truths
that we're going to get through in this
episode
but one of the words that's going to
come up a lot is attachment can we
define our terms before we get started
what is attachment
absolutely that was a question i got a
lot during that thread
attachment is the way that two human
beings securely connect
to other to each other um it's the
belief that someone will care for you
that someone will put up with you that
someone genuinely wants to help you and
that if you make a mistake
the other person is going to give you an
opportunity to correct that mistake
it's the belief that your relationships
are secure enough that they can't be
just blown up by accident and that other
people aren't trying to exploit you
healthy attachment is built on love it's
built on mutual sharing and it's built
on understanding so if i
hurt you you're going to give me an
opportunity to say adam that really hurt
me you know i
this is what i need from you going
forward so we can continue that
relationship
um and we're not trying to exploit each
other and get everything out of each
other that we can we're trying to go
forward so that both of us are
benefiting mutually
even if we over give to the other person
it's fine because we trust they'll do
the same for us someone with an
attachment issue
the fundamental belief underlying that
is that they are not
worthy of love that there is something
deeply wrong with them deep down on the
inside
and that everyone else can see it but
they have no idea what it is so they can
never let that out
they can never share anything inside of
them with other people
and they're just going to be stuck in a
series of trying to earn
love from other people earn approval
from other people
and earn so much so that other person
will read their mind
figure out what they need and then do it
out of gratitude without ever
learning who you really are on the
inside that's detachment that's what i
call detachment
it's not something that's very well
studied there's very few experts doing
it i'm one of the few people in the
united states really covering this topic
another one is dr robert glover he's a
genius
surpassing my work um but it's it's
something that needs to be studied
because this attachment underlies so
much of mental health
and we treat mental health from the
disease model
more than we do from a symptomology
model so instead of looking at
depression and saying this person has
depression
that's a disease we need to fix the
disease i would look at depression and
say
what what is that growing out of what
purpose does that serve and what's the
underlying issue
in my case that's almost always
attachment got you that's interesting
yes we're going to go through attachment
a lot so let's get into it we can do the
first one i've
uh curated a list of some of my
favorites
from that tweet list and we're going to
get through as many as we can and like i
say if
the listeners want to play along at home
they can go and check out the full tweet
for the uh
the dvd extras and the behind the scenes
stuff so the first one
most women are disgusted when they
finally learn how the male
sex drive works then they test to see if
it's true
and when it is they start to like the
new power they hold
how does the male sex drive work how do
they test if it's true what's the power
so the male sex drive works on
stimulation
it works specifically on external
stimulation
you and i we see an attractive woman we
often become aroused we see her doing
something this is right this is how
pornography works
you see an attractive woman you don't
even know and you become aroused
now you are aroused and you need to
relieve that arousal
and then your brain starts checking off
lists okay how can i relieve this
arousal in a way that is least
socially damaging so we go through the
checklist you and i could see two rocks
together and say hey that kind of looks
like breasts
and then we start thinking about how
okay when can i get back home to my wife
to take care of this
um that's how the male sex drive
typically works it's a little more
nuanced than that but but typically
we see something or hear something we
become aroused we need to relieve it we
find a way to relieve it
kind of like monkeys the female sex
drive typically does not work that way
now you've got hormonal differences
throughout the month but just looking at
a general overview the way the female
sex drive tends to work is built on
emotional intimacy
so a female sex drive a woman will
become attached to a man
or a woman or whatever maybe they become
attached to a person
and then they experience sexual feelings
toward that person from an evolutionary
standpoint this makes sense because we
10 000 years ago hunting mammoths in the
neolithic age
we're going to try to populate our seed
to as many women as we can
women need to be very selective because
having a child during that difficult
time
was going to it's a huge risk and a huge
resource investment so they're going to
look for the best partner
who has the best qualities who's going
to stay and be securely attached
attachment and then their sex drive will
activate toward that person and they
will want to engage in sexual relations
with that person
so that's not just the cultural
phenomenon
or even kind of the front brain
phenomenon that we
as modern humans understand that women
have the
the um the way that they're able to step
into their own programming and say
well i can't sleep with them on the
first date i'm not a [ __ ]
all of the all of the cognitive reasons
but what you're saying is that there's
actually a more source code a baser
level of this
which actually is acts as a gatekeeper
to
arousal for women that doesn't permit
them to be aroused until some man has
crossed this threshold
it's so fascinating how
a lot of the cultural artifacts and the
behavioral
um uh ways that we operate
are just weird projections
of what the genes wanted us to do in any
case isn't that isn't that amazing
it's wonderful so i i practice
evolutionary psychology it's where i get
a lot of my basis from and it
it blows people's minds when you share
these things with them and say okay
ten thousand our brains aren't meant for
modern day cubicle world and therapy
world our brains are meant for 10 000
years ago neolithic age
we're barely discovering that if you eat
corn and poop it out
new new corn will grow next year barely
figuring that out
that's what our brains are meant for
they're not meant for this modern day
okay i have a condom
that's not really how it works and the
female sex drive is built
to keep them and their children and the
species alive
they really are the sex gatekeepers in
that regard now that tracks down to what
the woman believes she is worth
so if she has attachment issues and
believe she's worth dirt
she might have sex on that first date
with multiple partners
just desperately trying to get them in
earn their approval earn their attention
um so if you have a culture then used as
a tool it's used as a bait
right so if you have a whole culture of
women with attachment issues and they're
driving the value of sex down through
the floor well
i'll leave that to your imagination yeah
okay so
they learn how the male sex drives works
they're disco why
are women disgusted when they find out
that men are uh
so kind of shallowly turned off i don't
typically when i work with them they
don't believe that
um so i worked with a lot of couples and
i would explain this to the female
partner and she'd say no there's no way
a man
two rocks a man couldn't see two rocks
and be a trap no
and she'd look at him and he's sitting
there like
and and she starts to realize okay wow
this actually may be true and then
they'll go home
for a week and then they come back the
next week and she's like she'll say oh
my gosh
you were so right like yeah that is how
he works i'm realizing it
and then they start to realize wait a
minute that's how he works i can just
like that all i got to do is flash a
little skin at him and i have and then
they start picking that up
a lot of women who go into sex work um
go into
strip clubs and whatnot they fee they
report feeling tremendously empowered
part of that is because they learn very
quickly how the male sex drive works and
they can just
boom like that if they want they wanted
that guy to drop 10 grand
well they can do it um and they can make
those men
approve of them get that approval for
them it's an instant win button they
just hit the butt they flash a little
skin they hit the button
he comes over to her women perceive male
sexual
attention as love and affection because
again
that's what they would be doing if they
were giving you sex it would be giving
you love and attention and saying you
are a good partner i want you
when a man gives sexual attention it's
like hey i need something right now
you're the best you
um that's how they perceive it so
they're perceiving it as that love and
affection
so that leads all kinds of problems but
yeah it gives women
tremendous sense of control when they
can push a button
anytime they need affection and
validation they know how to push that
button and that
i've seen that improve marriages tenfold
70 percent of divorces are initiated by
women
but as a couple's therapist i've never
seen
even one divorce where the husband
didn't have attachment issues
how did those manifest yeah so the 70
statistic you can pull that off online
um roughly 70
of divorces are initiated by women
actually why do you think that is
you know it's interesting um men with
attachment issues they tend to just
stick around
until they can find something better but
a lot of men don't a lot of men just sit
and just coast
or sit in stew and they think this is
the best i'll ever get
women as they have children a lot of
women typically
if both partners come in with attachment
issues neither one believes that they're
worthy of love
and they think they have to keep
everything secret and locked away and
earn love when the woman has a child she
starts to crave for the husband to be
attached to that child
and when she finds that he's not able to
she sees the child growing up being
anxious being stressed saying i wish
daddy spent more time with me
and she starts pushing him to do that
but they they joined when they both
couldn't do that
so it shifts her attachment a little bit
and it starts to make her resent
the husband and resent how he treats her
she puts more pressure on him
he starts feeling attacked he puts more
pressure back on her and attacks without
understanding what she's doing or why
um often times i treat a lot of partners
where the women are in their
late 30s early 40s and the marriage just
detonates because the children hit you
know 13
14 years old and she figures it's if
they're old enough they could survive a
divorce
i can't do this anymore he's hurting the
kids emotionally hurting them by not
being attached to them he's yelling at
me i'm out of here
and the guy's like oh what are you doing
hey we were fine nothing has changed i'm
the same person i was at the beginning
that's usually what i see is the woman
tries and tries i've written a book
um i'll plug that called exhausted wives
bewildered husbands where the woman has
tried
everything she can to make him change
and he is completely bewildered about
why she's upset um
that that's the most common dynamic and
divorce dynamic and attachment dynamic
that i've seen is where the woman just
tries and runs herself to death
and he will not change because he
doesn't understand what she's trying to
do
what's the way around that how can men
be more perceptive and women be more
effective
it's not even that um again going back
to 10 000 years ago men tend to be
active creatures we act upon our
environment
um we go out and we see a problem we go
out and we hunt we you know everyone's
hungry i'm gonna go hunt to mammoth
we see a problem we find the solution
that tends to be what we do women tend
to be reactive creatures
um they they see they see something here
and they react to it they see us going
out and acting
they react to us and figure out ways to
to embrace that and utilize that
they react to their environment um just
typically as a general overview
um women can almost never change men in
that regard
you pressuring him can almost will
almost never change him
and saying i need to feel this um it
just doesn't work
that's why a lot of men once the divorce
is initiated
suddenly he panics and he says okay now
i need to change
he sees i got a problem right
there's something to face he doesn't get
it when it's like well you should just
talk to the kids more
he's like why why would i do that that's
not what we do in this family
he doesn't act until his environment
changes and he sees a problem and it
forces him to act
so a lot of the work is educated when i
did couples counseling a lot of it was
educating the men
on why what they're doing is a problem
why there is a problem and then how to
solve that problem
that was a lot of what it was it and
then the female partner typically
once he changes she begins to respond to
his new changes as he's providing more
emotional intimacy
because the attachment piece um the
female sex drive works on emotional
intimacy so when you see a partner get a
couple get together
and they have all this sex at the
beginning and then the sex tapers off to
zero and they have it once a month or
every other year
kind of thing that's because the female
sex drive has now dried up because hers
is built on long-term emotional intimacy
after the initial short burst
so that she responds to him so the way
to fix that
when i said i've never seen any couple
with where the man didn't have an
attachment
i might have been exaggerating a little
bit there for twitter
but the vast vast majority of couples
i've ever worked with
the man has an attachment issue the
female often does too
but i've never seen a woman even an even
a really broken woman i've never seen
her divorce
a healthy man i've never seen that in
all my couples counseling years
i don't know if that's because women
just innately recognize that value so
they'll continue to respond to him until
they change
i have seen it where the man had
sort of attachment issues and had
autistic features
and wasn't fully equipped to engage with
those emotional aspects i have seen that
but even then it wasn't divorced it was
just she was
the female partner would rage out of
control with these emotions and he would
just not know what to do but there was
actually no talk of divorce
so yeah that's that's typically where
that comes in if the man is incapable of
forming those emotional connections and
feeding that emotional intimacy
eventually a female partner gets
exhausted and she calls it quits and he
has no idea why because it seemed like
it was working just fine
and that brings me on to the next one
which is husbands who complain about
having zero sex
have no idea how the female sex drive
actually works i'm gonna guess that this
is actually interlinked
yes it is exactly so i've worked with a
lot of couples where they have sex once
a year
um which is horrifying to contemplate
but it's
it's often because the husband number
one doesn't ask he's waiting for his
wife to jump on him like a jungle
predator and so he died he tries to
figure out how to just entice her
by giving her things or you know
flashing her or whatever
but he's not recognizing that by
diminishing the emotional intimacy he's
actually
killing her sex drive it's not that she
just has no sex drive he's actually
sending the wrong signals when you don't
talk to her about issues when you don't
talk to her about
some feelings i'm not saying sobbing
uncontrollably in her lap
but when you don't open up and express
who you are on the inside the message
you're sending is that you don't trust
her
you don't value her as an advisor as a
partner
um and that you aren't intending to
stick around for very long so
on a longer scale the message you're
sending is i'm going to find the next 19
year old blonde girl who wanders by and
i'm gonna go follow her instead of you
so the woman starts to disconnect from
you
that is interesting i think so many of
the points that you bring up today
are to do with the fact that the ones to
do with
um couples at least to do with the fact
that
men presume that women operate on men's
programming
and women presume that men operate on
women's programming
bingo we try and extrapolate out
the way that we feel what i what i would
want
what i would do men want to come in
solutions oriented women want to come in
and make everybody food or whatever it
might be and
neither of the people want that um so
and this is
i think one of the reasons why i have so
much
love for the evolutionary psychology
movement and also for threads like the
one that you wrote
because it doesn't actually take that
much to just be able to see it's like
learning a cognitive bias
as soon as you learn as soon as you
learn availability bias
or as as soon as you learn uh the
fundamental attribution error
you you think that guy's not an [ __ ]
maybe he was just late for work yes
like you know what i mean when you get
cut up in traffic the classic examples
so yeah i think um
that's why that's why it's important
because only with the
awareness can you actually start to
progress through these things
um this this next one is is one of my
favorites
if your child is an [ __ ] it's your
fault
even if it's the other parent's fault
it's your fault for picking them
take some responsibility correct so
i i say that healthy people don't
typically pick
unhealthy partners if your partner is
unhealthy
something about you was either unhealthy
or naive and not aware of what needed to
happen
we see a lot of that generational issue
here in the west
i have a whole talk i give about how
attachment has been breaking down
degenerating here in the west since 1918
since world war one
it's been a systematic just breakdown of
attachment here in the west
i won't get into that today because
that'll take up the whole hour but
yeah that's that right there um
boy my brain wandered off and on that
path why
as a parent you can never
undo the other half because your child's
brain
as they're growing up when you're when
your child is small
a little brain is looking at cause and
effect and it's
it sees itself as every cause as the
point or the point of origin for
everything that happens to it because
it's learning about gravity right if i
drop my
sippy cup of the side of my high chair
it hits the ground and it splashes
everywhere i made that happen
the child is learning about cause and
effect so it also blames itself for
everything so when we put a child in
daycare
um we're abandoning the child for 12
hours a day then when we're around it
we're exhausted we don't have time to
take care of it
or engage with it emotionally the child
starts the child's brain says there must
be something wrong with me that's
causing that
if we abuse a child the child's brain
says what am i doing that made this
person hit me
things like that the child's brain is
thinking that so if
you are a great parent and the other
parent is an [ __ ]
um the child's brain says 50 of people
are going to treat me horribly
and that parent is the honest one so
maybe the the
nice parent is just being nice to me
maybe it's a 50 50 shot or maybe i
really don't deserve any love at all
so i see this a lot when i work with
single moms who bring their children in
about 10 years old suddenly
they have this massive outgrowth of
anxiety and they're not sure where it's
coming from um they picked a partner
who is going to hurt their children
emotionally at least
and now the child is grappling with
these attachment issues under the
surface
it is still that parent's fault for
picking that partner
you don't have to feel bad but you
probably should own up to it
don't sit there and yell at the kids and
say hey what's wrong with you i've been
a good parent
i see that a lot that defensiveness if
i've been a great parent why are you
this way i should have made up if you've
been a good parent one of two
you've been 50 of a good family that's
another way to look at it
correct so i'm not trying to slap single
moms with guilt there and say you know
your deadbeat the deadbeat dad is your
fault
it's not what i'm aiming for but you do
need to take ownership of the fact that
one
you picked him so you have to a
responsibility to listen to that child's
hurts
let that child vent at you sometimes um
don't take it personally that you're not
super mom don't take it personally that
you're
not both mom and dad take some ownership
of the bad relationship that you brought
this child into
you don't have to saturate in guilt but
take some of that ownership and give the
child permission
to act out in a certain way as they
solve their problems and their wounds
otherwise they won't solve their
problems and their wounds they'll come
at you with these problems
you will reject them because you're
being defensive and that will create two
bad parents that this child now has to
overcome
yeah serious it's i mean that that that
is uncomfortable obviously we
these women who are raising two kids and
working two jobs and doing all this sort
of stuff
it does from the surface it can sound
uncompassionate to say well you did
choose the father but
the bottom line like that's that is the
truth you did choose the father
and the the ignorance of the fact or
bearing it under the rug isn't going to
make it go away
the only way that you can account for
whatever has occurred and the effects
they're in
is by admitting okay and i think this is
i had this conversation the other day i
think this is why the rationalist
movement is
sort of post scientific utilitarian
learn all the cognitive biases
biohacking movement
i think that's why it's got so much um
momentum at the moment
because it allows chaotic individuals
who are very untransparent to themselves
and don't really understand how the
world works surrounded by
infinite complexity it allows us to feel
like we can just
bring a tiny bit of that world under
control again
i can just try and wrangle some of this
chaos into order
and um yeah again this is these are the
these are the
the psychological cognitive biases okay
next one uh
it's okay to be sad that doesn't mean
you're depressed it's okay to be worried
that doesn't mean you're anxious
it's okay to experience trauma that
doesn't mean you have ptsd
not everything is a diagnosable issue
so diagnosis has to have multiple pieces
you have to fit the full criteria
and and some people can fit the full
criteria of a diagnosis but it also has
to
impact that quality of life especially
in
work function occupation school
relationships it has to cause a
detrimental effect
that crosses a threshold that's what
gives you a diagnosis
so you can experience a traumatic event
and not have post-traumatic stress
disorder
you can be sad for a lengthy period of
time and not have full depression
especially if it's not
impacting those qualities now we tend to
over diagnose here in the united states
and say i've been sad for three days i
have depression
but that's not the case if you're fully
functional you don't have
you most likely do not have diagnosable
depression
that has skewed a lot as as we've jumped
into
the effect of trying to treat things in
advance before they get too bad
but again we treat depression as a
disease here in the united
states at least so you're trying to
treat a disease isolated from the rest
of the individual and say it has nothing
to do with your life let's just throw
medication at you so
there's kind of a fine line you need to
walk there but it's okay it is really
okay to be sad
um the the the dsm that we use here in
the united states diagnostic statistics
manual
um gives at least two weeks of
consistent sadness
um for grief what we call bereavement
there was the
with the grief exception wasn't it yes
yes so we give two weeks
in the united states there's a minute
how long you're allowed to be that's how
long you're allowed to be sad when
someone dies that's it has to be a
minimum of two weeks of grief before you
even qualify
for diagnosis it can be longer it can be
complicated grief
um but two weeks of grieving is is more
or less what they have assumed
is the average here in the united states
um
that doesn't cross a threshold so yeah
you can when someone dies you're going
to be sad you are not instantly
depressed the moment someone dies
um you're not instantly just because
you're worried a little bit you don't
you shouldn't really call it anxiety as
much
um because that that is such a clinical
term and say i am anxious i'm being i'm
feeling anxiety right now
you can it's it's a lot better just to
use the word and say you know i'm
worried right now
how long has it been everybody that's
listening how long has it been since
you heard someone say that they were
worried versus
that they've said that they're anxious
i'm anxious about this thing that's
coming up well are you or are you
worried
because the specifics of that i imagine
from someone who understands the
clinical side of this are actually quite
important
but the phenomenological way of how it
feels
yeah it's just someone using different
words it's just someone getting a
synonym
the thesaurus out and deciding to use a
different word and and it might be okay
to say clinically that you
feel anxiety in that moment you're not
diagnosing yourself a generalized
anxiety disorder
um but using clinical words in your
self-talk
and to discuss yourself using those
clinical words just hammers them home
and makes them such a reality
i i have anxiety right now well
okay but let's back up a step before you
go to that extreme of a step and just
say
what what kind of anxiety is that are
you just worrying
are you nervous or all these other words
we used to use
don't don't don't go the full diagnostic
word on yourself if you can prevent it
yeah if you if you don't have to say i
experienced trauma
yeah maybe that is maybe that is a
fairly scientific way but
maybe you just say you know what i i had
a really difficult experience
there's a challenge that i faced and
there were some really bad pieces to it
but
you know what i'm doing better now i
think everyone needs to cool it on some
of the diagnostic
words that we use even some of the the
scientific words that we use on
ourselves
are they effective are are they are they
correct
maybe so but it doesn't do us any good
to go around pathologizing everything
that we feel either
correct that's exactly what i had in my
head it feels like
modern culture kind of upregulates or
upscales
the severity and this clinicalness and i
think um
i think part of it stems from what i was
talking about earlier on people wanting
to wrangle that chaos into order
if they can give it a label that sounds
official and professional and medical
and like there's a diagnostic for it
it's like well at least i know i can't
control this chaos but at least it's got
a name that can be understood in the
medical community
as opposed to and also maybe part of it
i think this actually might be a big
part of it maybe part of it
is that people want to justify why
they're so affected by
negative emotions and by giving it a
grander sounding name a more
catastrophic sounding name it almost
legitimates the fact that they're
affected by it
i don't want to admit that i'm the sort
of person that gets just worried and
actually would be worried about
something
i don't want to say that i'm the sort of
person that would be sad about something
i would experience
trauma no no it has to be depression or
anxiety or ptsd
because it legitimates how affected i
feel by giving it this bra
this grander term the contrasting effect
actually helps to relatively bring it
down
yeah it also forces the other person
involved in that conversation hearing
you describe yourself that way
it forces them to validate you and take
you seriously and take that because
otherwise
they're denying anxiety they're denying
these clinical terms
i think we've weaponized a lot of those
diagnostic criteria as well to try to
force reactions out of other people
most depressed men probably don't need
medication
even the ones who do need it more than
even the ones who do
need it more than just medication
depressed men
need purpose a mission and the power to
accomplish that mission
give a man those three things and he can
crawl over broken glass with a smile
so male depression um from my personal
experience
treating it but also from everything
i've read from research that i've read
male depression is different from female
depression in that male depression tends
to focus on learned helplessness
powerlessness men need a mission
in life and they need to believe that
they can go fulfill that mission they
need to be able to take steps
there's a reason that impotence is such
a big deal for men not just
not just sexual impotence but emotional
impotence
life impotence you need to be able to go
out and
do what you need to do you never have to
have a purpose in life
and be able to accomplish that purpose
and if you can do that
look at men in i was just reading um
an old duck uh old document la from
world war ii actually it was discussing
the bombings in in um
in london and
the psychological impact of that of men
who were
hospitalized prior to the bombings
hospitalized for severe
mental health problems schizophrenia uh
major depression some of them were
catatonic in hot in mental hospitals
prior to the bombings
um there were doc there's documents
showing um that those men
some of them got up and started driving
ambulances they got out of their
catatonic
state and started driving ambulances
through the street
helping with with rebuilding helping
with keeping people safe
all of a sudden these men came back to
life because now they had a defensive
war to fight
a clear clear win state and a clear
losing state and they could do it
they had something in front of them they
could accomplish this is why women men
are crushingly depressed
we try to do anything we can to make us
feel like we can accomplish something
so man who is agonizingly worried
about something in his life and feels
like there's nothing he can do about it
will all of a sudden obsess over the
smallest little project in his life that
makes no sense to anyone else
it could be a video game it could be
miniature little painting miniature
soldiers it could be anything
but that's what he can control and he
has to have that sense of control for
him to have life purpose
now a lot of that purpose comes from our
relationships with other people
we need to have right it can be that
that protector and provider role
of i'm a man and i'm protecting and
providing for my family so when we lose
a job
we can't provide for our family now we
feel like our mission is lost there's no
hope of providing for our family as our
job search
drags on and on and on we're now useless
the depression starts to set in as we
get what's called learned helplessness
of i will never get a job it will never
get better
that's that's that's really the piece
there's nothing i i have no mission and
no purpose in life starts the depression
and or or there's nothing i can do about
it that starts the depression and then
there's
and it will never get better that's what
starts the suicidal depression of
suicidal thoughts of
if i'm never going to get better and
it's never going to stop then what get
what else should i do i just need to
stop this pain
that's really what starts rolling in
that male suicide and
providers typically treat male
depression as they would treat female
depression which is more built on
women are men are problem solvers women
are relational
typically in their thinking women female
depression typically comes from not
feeling loved
or feeling useless to the people that
you love that's what female depression
tends to come from
they need to be loved and they need to
feel useful to the people that they love
if they have those two pieces women can
overcome just about anything there's
cases of women overcoming
women experiencing sexual assault and
having no ptsd whatsoever
female pows i was reading a report on a
female
american female pow over in iraq was
captured
and held hostage and and raped numerous
times i think it was i think it was iraq
um and then released and they checked
her for mental health symptoms and she
said
you know yeah it was bad but the sexual
assault wasn't the biggest thing in my
life
as she was flying home to her husband
and she and she was just glad to go home
and they checked her and evaluated her
numerous times that's something that we
we think of like how could someone
endure that without
no they checked her multiple times she
said you know i have a loving husband
and children i'm going to go home and
take care of them
boom she was useful to her family and
she was loved by her family
um we treat male depression
like female depression we try to make
men feel validated we try
therapists often try to make men feel
validated we try to make men
feel like people care about them we try
to make men feel
the way women want to feel and when men
don't respond to that we shame them for
not going to therapy
we tell them men are just stubborn men
just don't men would i saw a post on
twitter not long ago men would rather
lift weights than go to therapy
well yeah because that makes them feel
powerful one of the number one things
when men are depressed that i i
encourage them to do is start lifting
weights
because you can see the physical changes
in your body and you feel
powerful again you say i can make this
change happen well then i can go make
that change happen
that's the number one way to get men
back in and start focusing on their body
so
that's that one yeah male depression is
100 different
i love that i have never met a young
woman with sexual trauma who didn't
believe it was somehow her fault
part of this is the need to believe she
can prevent it in future
admitting it's beyond her power is worse
than feeling guilty
so this goes back to the male sex drive
and women not understanding it when a
woman is
raped young woman typically she says why
did he feel emotionally
toward me in that way what did i do to
inspire his emotions toward me
because again female sex drive is driven
by emotion how did i make him hate me so
much
and also does also feel close enough to
me to rape me
that's the female it's often the female
thinking so their first thing is what
did i do to encourage him
how did i encourage him it could be a
guy that grabbed her and dragged her
into an
alley and she'd never seen him before
and she will still say what was it about
me that encouraged him to do that
empowering and i i hate the word
empowering because it's used so often
now but it really is
empowering a female trauma victim by
helping her understand how the male sex
drive works
one of my other tweets in that thread
that drew anger like a lightning rod
was talking about um helping female sex
trauma
victims understand that rape is not
personal
um and man i got so many angry messages
from from people why do you think that
was victims
um because it's shocking because it is
personal to them
and this female sex drive is incredibly
personal
focused on the person of course but to
the man it could have been
if you'd replaced that person with
somebody else right place right time
same
even more incident would have occurred
even more than that for a man to commit
rape he doesn't see the woman as a
person he sees her as an
object to be used so he it is not
personal to him any more than him
shoving a chair with his foot was
personal the rape was not personal to
him it was just something that he just
did to relieve that
and feel powerful usually feel powerful
himself
all those things they boil over in bad
really bad ways
but yeah that women are when i say you
know what
we need to recognize that rape was not
personal and it had nothing it actually
had nothing to do with you
you were just the most convenient victim
in that moment that he was able to grab
and use
he was able to groom you he was able to
get a hold of you but it had nothing to
do with you and when they recognize that
they they fight it tooth and nail most
of the time because that doesn't make
sense to their way of thinking like he
he had forceful sex with me why would he
do that if there was no emotion attached
to it
um another piece of it is the female
body
experiencing sexual assault often will
orgasm
um not because she's enjoying it but the
the orgasm um forces the um the cervix
to dip
down into the vagina in the bottom of
the vagina and
drink up um essentially drink up the
semen that is there
and pull it up into the uterus so an
orgasm actually impulse that
that semen into the uterus at a greater
level um
that stimulates that birth so the female
sex drive again 10 000 years ago
not sex drive the female sexual
reproduction
ten thousand years ago if she's going to
be sexually assaulted her body will say
i'm at least going to get something good
out of this and make a child with this
because
if this guy has power enough to do this
then my child will have some sort of
power
it's a weird white line to walk um but
if she's able to do that her body will
then take the
horrible thing that is happening and
create this life
from it and draw some good out of it
crazy
that is the female body drawing good out
of this horror that is happening to her
and that's one of the positive
explanations for why some
sexual assault victims will orgasm
during yes
that's often why is because it's their
body forcing them to they don't enjoy it
and they feel so deeply ashamed
afterwards so when i would work with
female sex crime victims i would say
i would get them to a point where they
were comfortable and i'd say okay
did you i and i would explain all most
women experience an orgasm
against their will not because they
enjoy it because the body is designed to
do that
and they feel a lot of shame around that
as if they secretly liked it somehow
did you did you have that experience and
most of them will
be they'll start crying and they can't
speak and then they'll say yes i did
and i walk them through like that is
okay that does not mean you enjoyed it
your body was designed to have that
orgasm so that you could pull
something good from that horrible thing
that was happening this is why it
happened and then once you have that
orgasm
you get a flood of oxytocin um which
bonds you to the person that is sexually
assaulting you at that time so that's
then they could develop complicated
feelings toward that person
if that person was someone they knew
before they they feel attached to them
and they say well
i really hate them but i don't know like
we had that moment
their brain forcibly bonds them to that
person and this is
stockholm syndrome because if a woman 10
000 years ago was captured from her
tribe
and then raped by a guy her brain would
start bonding her to that guy and would
have a child
and then she could survive in this new
tribe and raise that child if she had to
um it's not pretty it's not pretty and
it's not justification for anything but
that that is the mechanism from an
evolutionary perspective that that's why
that's happening
and that that infuriates female sex
crime victims when you talk to them the
first time because they
can't wrap their brain around how how he
could be acting
upon her like a chair and how her body
could be doing that
has so much correct her body betrayed
her and he betrayed her
um but once they come out of that and
they realize those things and they
accept them oh there is so much healing
that's i can i can get
women who cannot have sex after sex
after rape they cannot have sex with
their male partners without all these
flashbacks i can get to the point where
they can initiate sex
and have a fruitful wonderful sex life
with their new partner with
virtually zero flashbacks or issues
and use those things to actually develop
more intimacy with their partner in the
future
as long as they accept those earlier
components those are the pieces that are
missing they have to understand those
two pieces
why their body did what it did and why
that person did what they did
if they can understand those there is so
much healing in those
how much do you think that um
natural predilection for the body to
respond in that way to
aggressive sex leads into rough sex
being
a desire for certain women consensually
yeah um it isn't necessarily that the
rough sex is activating the orgasms
rough sex a lot of
the rough sex what it does is it
how do i want to express this it
expresses to the the female partner how
strong and ready the male partner is so
it's more it's more psychological then
i i would say so um it's dominance
you're displaying dominance which means
you're the kind of person who has
dominant features which means your
children will probably have dominant
features
and and that emotional dominance to
survive in a neolithic age
ten thousand years ago so multiple
orgasms to try to get as much of that
that seeming up into the uterus as
possible
there's some people there will be some
people they won't because everyone that
listens to this podcast clever
but there might be some people who
stumbled upon this podcast what are they
talking about
like rough sex is just rough sex and
like what do you mean
he's like no no no no what you think is
happening and why you like the things
you like
aren't the reason that you like them you
are the puppet on the end of the strings
that your jeans are playing around with
that is that's that this is why dude i
could go on about evolutionary
psychology forever because it's so
fascinating
it's even more complicated than that
because the female sex drive um during
most of the month is fairly neutral
and and it likes her partner the female
sex drive during
during ovulation period she has more of
a desire for males with masculine
sharp angular features and more rough
sex during the ovulation period
and then during menstruation periods she
is looking more for male with softer
features
different completely different from the
male that she was looking for during
ovulation
and very different sexual activity also
during that time
so during the time of the month women
are also looking at different kinds of
sex and even different kinds of partners
and even beyond that during pregnancy
before pregnancy saliva they have women
taste saliva samples from different
partners
and women with before pregnancy prefer
the saliva taste of partners from a
different genetic
pool than them after pregnancy they
prefer the saliva taste from partners
from a similar genetic pool to them and
even closer into like
they're very very similar down to almost
family
so this is why a lot of women during
pregnancy are disgusted by their
husband's smell and taste and everything
because her body is now saying okay i
got pregnant by this guy over here i
need to pull back to my core family and
tribe to raise this child and be per
maximize my safety child safety so she's
like ah
a lot of women sometimes won't even let
their husbands touch them during
pregnancy and the sex drive tanks
and but she doesn't want to say like hey
you disgust me and you smell bad
but my jeans are telling me that you do
my jeans are telling me to get the hell
away from you yeah what i learned
in steve stuart williams uh the apo
understood the universe
have you heard of the westermark effect
no i haven't okay so the westermark
effect
is the mechanism by which
incest is avoided oh yes okay
what happens is during the early years
of childhood
you and the other children of your age
that you spend significant amounts of
time with within your family
you imprint on each other in a way that
causes your body to find them
sexually repulsive essentially um
now the problem comes when you
and a biological sibling have been
separated at birth
then you meet back up so you've avoided
this westermark window
yeah and then you meet back up later in
life and you find quite to your dismay
that you may be physically and sexually
attracted to this person
even though all of the ethics and the
morality and the culture tells you that
it's wrong
and everybody else doesn't want to have
sex with their brother or sister so they
know that it's wrong
correct the westermark effect is this
window i can't quite remember
how long it goes up until um but yeah so
you see
non-genetically related
siblings perhaps like cultural siblings
have been put together social siblings
have been put together in the same house
when they've grown up
who have every right to have sex with
each other
being completely repulsed yeah and
perhaps a separated sibling come back
into the picture
and then be an object of sexual desire
yes oh it's huge i don't know that's
that's what the name of that is what's
the mock effect yeah yeah
thank you thank you for the education um
no but i do know that
it's it is astounding the number of
um children and especially daughters
who reunite with fathers who were never
in their lives who then have sex with
those fathers
it is astounding it is noteworthy if you
go look up the statistics on that
why do you think that is um
well it really depends on where she is
in her cycle and then emotionally
yeah yeah um being having your father
pulled away from you um
we often as humans we get our sense of
self-worth from our opposite sex parent
so if she grew up without that father
her brain is telling her that i am
worthless no my even my dad didn't want
me
um so getting back with him as an adult
or as a teen
there are so many complicating variables
and if she has gone out and sought that
that sexual attention from other people
as a means of validation
then she gets back with that father and
then that's the ultimate way to get that
ultimate validation from him as a man
and she doesn't know any better she
hasn't passed that that western mark
window um it creates so many problems
for those
those young women it is yeah if you go
look at the statistics of the number of
young women
who re reunite with a distant father
they were not raised by and then have
sex with him
it is it's something that no one wants
to talk about because it's so deeply
uncomfortable but it's
yeah it's real man women don't trust an
unstable or unreliable man
it's not the whining flaking lying
sneaking or excuses that specifically
erode her trust
these are symptoms of a deeper
instability that rings all her alarm
bells
she can forgive specific behaviors but
not the underlying issue
because it goes back to 10 000 years ago
what is going to keep her child alive
a man who has integrity tells the truth
does what he says he's going to do um
actually solves problems conscientious
honest
um capable of emotional intimacy and
connection
without being pathetic and sobbing on
the floor um
all of those features tie back into okay
he will keep me and my children alive
because ten thousand years ago if you're
pregnant
as a pregnant woman you're not gonna
waddle with a spear pick up a spear and
go waddling out to fight a mammoth
picture picture a group of 10 pregnant
women with spears trying to fight a
mammoth
well there's something very wrong with
that picture because every one of them
that dies now there's two lives being
lost
yes you don't want that 10 000 years ago
you don't want that now
um which is why we don't have pregnant
typically we don't have pregnant women
on the front lines in a battlefield
that's a failure of a society is if
you're pregnant women are on the
battlefield
so yeah women are looking for that
stability
women are looking for that in a male
partner and if you
don't provide that long term her body
just says
i can't have children with this guy so
it shuts down the sex drive
and then she starts sort of distancing
from you because you are so
unstable she can't trust that in you so
this is the thing
that young guys don't
understand about going to the gym so the
signal of going to the gym they think
that it's to do with right i'm gonna i'm
going to look good
and the aesthetic that what it is the
feeling of my body is what's going to
attract her
what i've come to realize or at least
believe is that it is far more
the signal of what sort of a person am i
to be the sort of person who can build
this sort of physique
i'm conscientious i'm reliable i'm
consistent i'm able to
have self self-reliance i'm able to
make goals and achieve them i'm healthy
i have surplus calories i have surplus
strength i have surplus testosterone
if you find me sexy by the
culturally defined this is what a good
body should look like plus v taper
that's already embedded blah blah
the sexy sun hypothesis suggests that we
are going to have children who will also
look like me that other women will also
want to have sex with which will
continue our genetic lineage more
quickly blah blah blah
so correct it's much easier to say to
guys like get bigger like big arms
equals lots of women
but it's it's a little bit more second
ordery and third ordery than that
yeah absolutely you know a healthy woman
is not going to see an attractive
stranger and try to have sex with them
in a bathroom
so the women you're going to attract by
being handsome like that who'll have sex
with you on the spot
are not going to be the healthy women
you want to have a relationship with but
women are women are visually attracted
to men they are there's a component
there but they're not
just going to have sex with you because
you're hot that that sort of
opens the door but you're 100 right the
messages you send to women
are much more important than how you
look that's why we see a lot of very
attractive women with very
ugly men who happen to have good other
features usually money
um but good other features think about
that
the one that the thing that i always use
is think about the funny guy
friend that you've got he's never single
if you've got that one person
that can always crush a conversation
really really funny
he's always going to have a girl because
he's able to add value
that's exactly right you have to go if
you if you know and i teach i have a
whole course that i teach on
to teach young men about how to attract
healthy women and what they actually
want from you and it's not what men
think
um if you want to attract a healthy
woman go back 10 000 years and say
what would women want 10 000 years ago
and why would they want it well they'd
want men with good social skills to
be good leaders and to unify the tribe
and have good emotional intimacy they
want men who have good
availability emotionally but they're not
pathetic and and fall apart at problems
they want men who solve
problems and aren't decisive are
decisive without being tyrants and
hurting people around them and [ __ ] and
telling you to shut up
um they want men who are pretty
physically fit who keep themselves up
um they you know they they want all
these good different features and the
more of those boxes you check
the higher quality of female partner
you're going to be able to attract
that's just how it is if now if you have
10 billion dollars in your bank account
all of a sudden your resource
acquisition exactly but then if that's
all you have
you're going to only attract a certain
type of woman yeah so
the more those boxes are the more the
boxes you check the better
one that i was told i found out
in this is also in the apo understood
the universe um
the body positivity movement in 2021
specifically for women is claiming that
our standards for beauty are culturally
constructed
so there was a ton of meta-analyses that
have been done around that
and what's been found this is quite
interesting so the
optimal um size for women that has
fluctuated a little because we're
memetic creatures right rene girard
found this out like we
we do imprint we want what we think
other people want us to want almost in a
way
and the size of women has fluctuated not
by much
but the preferable size has changed a
little bit but the thing that hasn't
changed is the waist to hip ratio
and the waist to hip ratio across all
cultures all
times and all countries
is always around 0.7 always
around 0.7 so it doesn't matter whether
you are
a thicker girl a thinner girl whatever
it might be
like if you can hit that hourglass shape
with the 0.7 waist to hip ratio
you're winning um and yeah that was that
is controlled for as many different
variables as you can get
pretty much and yeah 0.7 number to hit
that's so funny and it's true
and what i always tell women when i work
with women with low physical self-esteem
i always say
look you don't need to be a skinny
barbie doll type because you then you'll
only attract skinny barbie doll guys
who they like skinny barbie doll types
every guy has a type
you have a body type maximize the
effectiveness of your body type and
attract men who love your body type
and they will worship the ground you
walk on just just make your body type
work for you
and that's really what we should be
teaching women not that everything is
perfect and nothing is wrong
it's maximize the health of whatever
body type you have if you're a big thick
woman with big muscles and everything
cool
go there are dudes who will fall all
over themselves to win your heart
just maximize the healthiness of that
because female health and fertility if
you look at a lot of the female beauty
standards that men follow it it evokes
it displays fertility long hair means
you have
really good nutrition long healthy hair
means you have such good nutrition and
folate and everything in your diet
you can grow this huge luxurious mane
that doesn't look nasty and scraggly and
broken off
um that's just one aspect of female
beauty that shows
fertility here's another thing that i've
learned about
symmetry in faces so
the signal that symmetry and faces we
look at symmetrical faces and we think
someone like brad i think brad pitt and
angelina jolie were
one year or so they were voted like the
most symmetrical faces statistically
if you were to do a statistical analysis
of their faces they ended up being
and um it's very expensive genetically
to be able to create a symmetrical face
it's actually much easier to create a
lopsided face
um so the reason that we like
symmetrical faces
is not just that we tend to like things
that are neat and orderly
it's that it is a signal that this
person has
strong genetics and also you get the the
sexy son or sexy
daughter hypothesis through that as well
this this next one is
is cool um we've done away with teaching
children to build character
now we instruct them to assemble an
identity from things they hope will make
them interesting enough to earn love
yes so this goes back to attachment um
and it goes back to my
you know attachment has been
systematically broken and dismantled
worse and worse with each generation
over the last hundred years here in the
west
we've reached a point now where people
don't believe they are worthy of love as
an innate human being
we don't have an human dignity
much anymore now it's built on what are
what were you born as what skin color
were you
um what experiences have you endured
things that have happened to you innate
features
is what we look at and we define
ourselves now by innate features and by
and by things that have happened to us
in the old days
100 years ago people used to define
themselves based on their experiences
that
they had set out and created for
themselves
you were you know you were the
vanquisher of of whatever it might be
you
you were you were a baker you had set
out and made
this career but you were also the type
of character you were your your moral
character
defined who you were and it was based on
your actions
and not only the not only the good
things you did but also the mistakes you
made
and how you made up for them honor is is
a system not only of perfect behavior
and honor system
it's also built on how you respond to
challenges to your honor and how you
respond
yourself when you make a mistake
a person a man's honor is not just he's
perfect a man's honor is he
usually does the right thing and if he
doesn't he makes it right and he makes
amends and it comes out better than it
was before
we call that man honorable that's a lot
of work
and that requires people to put forth a
lot of effort
and it's hard and it's not fun
and so we
encourage people and we say you're not a
good person the belief is we're not a
good person anyway so i won't i won't
stand up when things go right i don't
have courage
i won't do the right thing that's not
who i am i'm not a good person so
this is the belief i'm innately flawed
so i'm always going to prove that i'm
worthless so
instead i will pick things that make me
interesting
and i will tell people that i am
interesting because of those things and
i will get attention
and that is what that's a lot of the
system that you see nowadays with a lot
of identity politics
the reason people def distill themselves
down to a
feature about them this is the genitals
i have these are the genitals i like
this is the color i
am that's not who they are as a person
but it's who they make themself
because they are afraid on the inside
usually that they don't have any more
moral fiber than that so if they pretend
to have more moral fiber that and
engage in a moral this is my character
they're going to lose and because they
have that innate insecurity about
morality on the inside
they can point out the sins of other
people against the identity code
and say you are a sinner because you
don't respect other people's identities
that makes you a bad person and by
pointing it out i am pointing out what a
good person
i am because i know the rules so well
that i can enforce them on you
that's how that is built that's exactly
how that is built it comes down to
attachment
once again dude that that strikes on
something that i learned
in uh robert wright the moral animal
and he says the reason that people love
scandal and to see the downfall of
others
is it allows them to feel the
indignation
the moral emotion of indignation whilst
having to do nothing moral to earn it
yes holy [ __ ] if that's not the truth
i'd like to start i just put the book
down when i read that i was like
scandal allows us to feel moral emotion
whilst having done nothing moral to earn
it like that is just
such an amazing insight and i i really
think that what you've just said about
um
people who perhaps internally don't have
a massively
developed sense of self-worth
identifying with group characteristics
and pointing out
the flaws of others to be able to
identify with their group
characteristics
this is the signal increasingly that i
am seeing
this sort of subtext tacit signal that
i'm seeing
when i encounter people mostly online
um because i live somewhere where
there's rational people um
when i see them online the first thing
that i think now is i wonder what that
person's hiding
i don't trust that person's moral fiber
because i don't know people who
genuinely
are honorable and virtuous and have
integrity
who act in that sort of a way who speak
in that sort of a way
and the first thing that it makes me
think is like you
you probably don't like yourself all
that much you probably
have abandonment issues attachment
issues
you are probably inside
ruthlessly unconfident that you are
to be liked or loved or competent
uh that you have any merit to be able to
achieve something in this world perhaps
there's the learned helplessness that we
said earlier on
the fact that look i can't compete i
mean this is is this not the craziest
thing that
most people who complain about status
hierarchies use
complaining about status hierarchies to
gain status by being outside of them
like that i'm not going to play your i'm
not going to play your capitalist
meritocracy game
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
take one step out and play my own
capitalist meritocracy game
but in a new set of rules where i just
do criticism and again it comes back to
feeling moral whilst having done moral
nothing moral to uh to deserve it
correct absolutely
uh you are better than your worst
mistake that you still measure yourself
by
the fact that you're still bothered by
it proves that you're better than you
were then
this is a lesson for all of us not just
with attachment issues but
a lot of people are haunted by a mistake
that they made
in the past and the fact is if you are
haunted by that mistake you now
recognize what a deeply terrible mistake
that was and if you were faced with it
again
there's almost no likelihood that you
would do it now um but we still measure
ourselves by it we still
remember it we still think man if people
found out about that they would laugh at
me they'd be mad at me
we are we are crushed by it and what i
tell people is when you make a mistake
and then you feel bad about that mistake
and you learn from it
the person you were is now dead and you
have
grown out of that new person much like a
a butterfly out of a cocoon
you are a new person because you've
reached a new moral threshold
you've identified a new line in the sand
you will never cross again
that's really where that comes down to
um it's a hard thing to accept it's it
is
the core of forgiving oneself uh i've
learned
from that here's what i've done about it
and that's what i tell people who are
haunted by a mistake is to say what have
you done about it
what would you tell the people if if the
people you hurt back then came back and
said you did this to me
what not not how would you excuse it but
what would you say
to tell them and show them
i made it mean something make that
mistake mean
something by changing who you are
fundamentally and how you approach other
people not just reactively but
proactively
make it mean something and that
definitively proves that you are a
different person now
that's really where it comes down to
isn't that why we love the zero to hero
stories or the bounce back stories
yes it is because it it makes their
early life
mean something and it shows that we can
do it too
the dying artist or the the failing
comedian or the the sort of um homeless
musician you know this sort of these
tropes that we have of the people who
have the talent
and maybe they did something bad in
their past but then they come back to do
something else there's something so
romantic about it
rob henderson um my buddy who does a lot
of evolutionary psychology and sociology
he tweeted something the other day
saying that the most popular narrative
on the planet is it's got a name and i
can't remember it but it's basically
um from high to low back to high
so you can um i was going to say wolf of
wall street but he didn't bounce back to
high
actually he was he was always high um so
but that's a different a different sort
but yeah hercules hercules would be a
great example of that right someone that
is
then isn't and then is again and um yeah
i think
it's setting an example for us this is
another one of the reasons why i think
that
people love tv shows
that have romance in them even if the tv
show
has nothing to do with romance it's a
doctor's surgery
it's a it's a comedy about nerds doing
nerd [ __ ] at
a university and researching stuff and
things like that there always has to be
a love
interest that why does there have to be
a love interest because
falling in love is so fundamental to
our understanding of the world that it
gives us hope that even if these
useless flawed creatures that i see on
tv and i feel like a real people
if they can do it then there's hope for
me as well yeah
most definitely and we love healthy
people love to see other people triumph
and even unhealthy people part of them
loves to see other people triumph
people like them if you're geared
100 toward earning approval from others
out of constant fear of abandonment then
sex becomes a performance based on fear
of doing it wrong
and the other person abandoning you
orgasm can be almost impossible under
those conditions
and there's a second one to this female
arousal is based on emotional intimacy
which you went through earlier on and
perceived security
which attachment issues undermine and if
all of her sex is a performance
there's no focus on her own body it's on
maximizing approval and by boosting her
partner's pleasure
i worked with a lot of young women who
had never experienced an orgasm
and when i say young women i mean women
in their late twenties
um early twenties and late twenties who
had never experienced an orgasm who had
been with
the same partners for sometimes for
years and years sometimes they were
married and
never experienced orgasm um because for
a lot of them
sex was a way to earn that love and
approval and feel like he really loved
her
that was that was her way of saying he
wouldn't have sex with me if he didn't
love me because my sex drive is built on
love and
and care so he must love me if he's
having sex with me
um and they were so focused on doing it
right
and making him happy and that was her
way of earning his love and approval
that
they had never experienced an orgasm
because most women have to
not like work at it that's like it's a
chore but i mean there's
there's a process of having an orgasm
for a female typically
um and if you're not engaged in that
process
odds are good you may not have an orgasm
at all so it was by teaching them
to step back from sex as a performance
art
and step into emotional intimacy with a
partner
and recognize that you know men men
typically like it once in a while when
their female
partner has an orgasm most men care um
teaching them to engage with that
process as an intimate moment
and give some of that validation back to
their male partner by allowing him to
give you an orgasm
instead of making him make it believing
many women do
believing feeling um as if as having an
orgasm and working toward one is a chore
for him that he's not going to want to
do
so that he will be turned off by you and
not want to have sex with you anymore
because you're forcing him to help you
have an orgasm
man that's a terrible chore to do um but
a lot of women have that feeling
internally when they
when they finally verbalize it out loud
they realize that's really silly but
that's for a lot of for any women
listening to this who have never had an
orgasm
really think about that really think
about that how much emotional intimacy
you actually have in your sexual
encounters if you are having no
orgasms doesn't mean you have to have
one every time
but if you have zero probably not a lot
of emotional intimacy there
think as well everybody has done
something
an activity where they should have been
focused on the
present on the visceral on what is
occurring but haven't been able to get
themselves out of their own head
they've been in a work meet a really
important work meeting or a job
interview
or anything and they should be
concentrating on what the other person
is doing or saying
and they can't stop thinking about why
they're thinking and then they think oh
i'm the sort of person that thinks about
why they're thinking while i'm supposed
to be doing
and it just starts getting louder and
louder and it spirals up and up and up
and up
and i imagine that during sex that's
probably what a lot of women that are
doing this sort of performance
performative
um sexual act are thinking they're
thinking like
am i i should do this and then it's been
maybe it's been 30 seconds and then it's
been
and you're like all of these bizarre
um narratives
that we tell ourselves um and i imagine
that that must be
super super common especially if they
maybe don't don't have a ton of
body confidence or just generally have
got themselves into this habit
big time one time one thing that i ask
women
who have not had an orgasm or who almost
never almost never have orgasms one
thing i asked them that ruined sex for
them
is what are you getting instead
what is it you're going into sex looking
for instead of an orgasm
and plenty of women plenty of healthy
women will say well sometimes i just go
into it looking to care for my partner
i'm getting emotional intimacy out of it
but not every single time not to the
point where they never have any sexual
pleasure and orgasm themself
if you are foregoing sexual pleasure
what are you trying to get instead
that usually ruins sex for a lot of
insecure women right there so because
then they stay
that narrative starts running in the
back of their head while they're having
sex they start thinking what am i
getting out of this oh no why am i on so
insecure
so sorry for that the last one
insecure men spend so much time trying
to please their wife
the way they please their own mother
that they force their wife into a mother
role
then they wonder why she doesn't
initiate sex anymore
so attachment like i've said comes it
starts when you're born
it starts the moment you're born babies
know their mother smell they know her
taste they know her voice they know
everything about her so
if you there are adopted out at birth
your brain starts telling you hey
something's not right here
um and it starts forming okay why did
why was i abandoned why was i lost why
didn't my mom keep me
so i've still i've seen a lot of men
with birth attack birth
adoption straight into loving parents
that have
horrible attachment problems and never
quite know why
but a lot of men are raised by single
moms depressed moms
detached moms anxious moms traumatized
moms
and the child because that shapes how
mom acts and responds and the energy she
has for the child and the words she says
and the lessons she teaches
it shapes that young man typically to
have attachment issues himself because
he says why is she acting this way well
it must be my fault
and so he pleases her by being a good
boy he pleases her by never putting too
many demands on her
never being messy always doing his
schoolwork
always doing what he's told he pleases
her
that way and that's how he earns her
approval when he goes into marriage
that's all he knows how to do
is to be a good boy so he goes into
marriage and tries really hard to be a
good boy
and that's not what women are looking
for in a male sexual partner
they want a man who is confident
a little bit dominant without being
domineering
that's why a lot of women are looking
for a dominant male partner feminists
some of the feminists i've treated have
have been some of the most
obsessed with finding men who will just
crush them with dominance especially
during sex
because they're really looking for it
and they don't think they're worth much
often um
that's neither here nor there but that's
that's what women are looking for
again ten thousand years ago are they
going to want a good boy
or do they want a strong confident man
who takes charge during problems
who um it proactively solves finds and
solves problems
who doesn't fall apart if she gives them
criticism
who does more than just go out and earn
a paycheck no they're looking for that
they're looking not for a good boy but
for a strong man
so they go forward they try to good boy
their way into sex they try to good boy
their way
into everything that they want but
they're afraid to ask for sex
so they have to do 10 nice things for
her and they are so sure that she will
be so overwhelmed by the night the good
boy things he does that he will earn
sex with good boy points and she will
initiate the good boy sex not
they don't even have to she'll just jump
on me and when that doesn't happen they
get regret uh
resentful toward their wife and she has
no idea what he's doing
and he he just seems really unconfident
and so she's not
super turned on by him but she'll she'll
have sex with him if he asks but he
never asks
he just punishes her for not having sex
with him so it just erodes the core of
that relationship and over a long enough
period he goes from being a good boy to
being a really resentful mean boy who
treats her like crap
because he thinks that she has betrayed
him by not doing
what by not rewarding him like a good
boy like his mom would
so those men often they stay emotionally
monogamous to
their moms their whole life because at
least with mom i can win love
by spending my good boy points i can't
earn love for my wife with good boy
points
so the wife and the mom are often in a
constant battle too so
emotionally monogamous i really like
that i think i stole that from um
dr robert glover if i remember right
that's really cool
just to bookend a lot of the
conversations we've had today been
around relationships
what are some of the main
errors that you have seen
clients of yours making when they've
been
setting out on relationships what are
the
main things to avoid doing not having
deep conversations up front i i tell
people
um like i i have a video course that
teaches young men how to have a first
date with a woman that will set them up
for
a having a wife basically how to turn a
first date into your wife
um it is all about doing the opposite of
what detached people do you don't hide
everything who you are on the inside and
your goals and your points because
you're not bad
you put it all out there you say here's
who i am
here's what i want here's my mission in
life here's the kind of partner i'm
looking for
on the first date boom you lay it on the
table and say here's
everything about me that i have not all
the bad things but here's
everything about what i want what do you
want
and you approach it like they did you
know 100 years ago they'd get
parents would get together and have a
discussion about okay are you right for
our family should we
and they'd arrange these matches you
have to do the same
you have to go out and and courtship
instead of dating don't date dating is
worthless
you are just spinning your wheels and
having sex with people that you don't
care about and that they don't really
care about you
and it's not going to work out because
you're probably going to meet people who
have attachment problems
people who have healthy attachments
don't tend to date they
they do courtship instead which is i'm
really interested in you
you have good features good enough that
i'm romantically attracted to you and
sexually attracted to you
here's what i want a relationship here's
what i'm looking for in the long term
how do those match up with who you are
and where you are and then you have that
conversation if the other person is able
to fully open up and say
yep this is who i am these are the
pieces of myself this is what i'm
looking for
they don't have to have a 50-year plan
with every step perfect and notebooks
filled with it
but if they're able to have those
conversations fully open and share who
they are in a confident manner they
probably don't have attachment issues
either
so you're vetting them for attachment
issues at the same time and if you're
not able to have those conversations you
may have attachment issues also
if you're having those you're displaying
if you're having the conversations
you're displaying that you have good
attachment
so yourself from having a conversation
with you i don't know if you're single
or married or what
um but if but have come across as a very
calm
confident assertive person you're not
you're not timidly waiting to see if i'm
done talking right you're having these
conversations you're educated
you're fit i can see the the muscle
outline in your skull
so you look pretty fit um you probably
would go on a date with a woman
and lay out exactly what you're looking
for you'd probably say hey you know what
i don't really want to waste a lot of
time here's what i'm really looking for
is you know i just i i want someone who
is going to be a good mother for
children i'd like to have children down
the line
it's good to have that discussion on the
very first date so that you don't get to
date
you know 500 six years in and say hey
how do you feel about having kids and
discover you're completely incompatible
chase down those compatibilities on the
very first date
do it that's what dinner should be for
and then don't have sex on the first
date because if the other person is
giving you sex on the first date they
probably don't have really good
boundaries or sense of self-worth
um especially looking at again how the
female sex drive works if she's jumping
into a risky relationship like that then
might not be the best option not saying
every woman who has sex on the first
date is a bad woman but just
the tendency is is there just be aware
of the trend um
myself when i applied all that with my
wife i've been married oh boy
i think i've been married 12 years now
little past 12 years
my wife and i we were engaged to be
married within two weeks of having met
no way like we pounded through the
conversations of this is what i want
these are my religious beliefs these are
my convictions these are my principles
this is my plan in life this is where
i'm aiming and at the time i was
22 i think i didn't have everything in
line i didn't have a perfect life vision
but i was able to tell her like
this is what i want and this is what i'm
looking for and she said that's exactly
what i'm looking for too
and it just it clicked so we were like
okay i want you and i don't want anyone
else to have you so let's get engaged
and we got married um 11 months
after having met so two weeks we were
engaged and then we were engaged for a
full year to watch each other go through
some crises
because you don't really know who
someone is until they go through a
crisis
and you vet them that way you see how
they act toward you you see how they act
toward other people you see how they
talk about other people
that's really when you get to know
someone's when they're out of when
things are out of their control how do
they react
so 11 months in we got married and yeah
we just had our 12 year wedding
anniversary uh a couple months ago so we
have three kids
she wants at least seven more or as many
as she can steal
off the street i don't know wow adam man
what an awesome story
i'm so happy for you man i'm so happy
and and and i that's what i try to teach
young men to do
and and is find a woman who is so
healthy that you can figure out within
two weeks
if you want to marry her or not and then
make the commitment don't hide don't sit
for six years
you know the people who who are together
for six years and never get married and
she's waiting for a ring
dude do you want do you want me to throw
in
one hour and 18 minutes into the podcast
you want me to throw in
two of the most uncomfortable truths
that i've totally forgotten about
the first one you may be familiar with
the cohabitation effect
yeah so the longer that you live with
someone before you get married the
shorter the marriage is going to be on
average essentially
um i wonder there seems to be a lot of
uh controversy or at least there doesn't
seem to be a defined answer for why
that's the case
one of them is that it's a potential
signal that um
you are good for me but i'm going to
keep the door open for now by not
committing to you formally
um are there any other explanations i
know i know that that matches up with um
the more partners you've cohabitated
with before marriage the less likely you
will be to get married or the more
likely you are to have a divorce if you
do get married
accepting the first one if that is the
first person you've ever cohabitated
with it may or may not have that impact
one thing that is also considered is
again females when they have that
that orgasm with a partner there's that
oxytocin release that bonds them to that
partner
we're actually not allowed to study if
that over a long enough time
affects a woman if she has sex with
multiple partners there isn't research
that i know of that's been done here in
the united states the apa
the american psychological association
here in the states back in the 80s
there was some research that they were
going to do and that research was binned
as as british people i think would say
bind
because it challenges the female
empowerment dynamic
of you can just have as much sex as you
want don't worry about it don't be tied
down to a partner
so it's really hard to find any research
that studies if a woman having sex with
multiple partners actually can cause
relationship damage or mental damage for
her
but the little research that exists does
seem to indicate that
there could be a feature there there
could be a component whether that's
based on the oxytocin bonding destroying
her ability to bond to partners securely
or
if it's just that she's more some people
say she's more aware of her options so
she keeps options open
um good or bad it doesn't really matter
why it's happening though it just
yeah there seems to be a correlation
yeah um so
i'm gonna i'm gonna do another another
one so the single the single biggest
predictor of extra marital sex is
pre-marital sex
the more partners you have before
getting married the more partners you
have when you're married
frequently and that's one of the biggest
indicators of divorce actually
interesting also
um just because again if you look at
attachment
you a lot of especially female partners
it cheapens sex
for them they need sex more because they
don't think they have any
character quality to draw a man so they
have to use the sex to draw him in
and then once they have that
relationship and that marriage then
then they're down to nothing because
they they've given him sex
now it's a marriage and they have to
build a marriage based on their each of
their characters and she doesn't have
character
um and neither does he probably because
he's picked this woman
who doesn't have connections it was
built on sex and never ever talking
about who you really are on the inside
for both partners because again he
picked her
he picked a partner who was okay with
never challenging that and never getting
super close both partners
said yeah you don't even want to get
close or have that discussion that
sounds great to me yeah for no re for no
reason at all i swear
um yeah that's so yeah honestly
premarital sex
a lot of it does come from those
attachment issues there was one that we
haven't covered in this one but we may
do
uh if i'm i'm super keen to get you back
on dude this has been awesome but
there was one that you you talked about
uh to do with people presume that you
have to have sex before you get married
to work out whether you're a good sexual
match with your partner but after
sure i mean that's a whole another uh
rabbit hole to go down i'm gonna leave
you with my favorite one
or my my least i can't work out if i'm
satisfied or terrified or
whatever it is with these truths but
every time i learn them i i i
think about them a lot um this one is
another robot rightism
from the moral animal evolutionary
psychology and
it was talking about one of the reasons
why a couple who has been together
over a significant period of time so
you're talking like
four years plus six years plus
and hasn't had children can find
themselves falling out of love
even if they meant not to have children
and were planning on waiting
and this is the evolutionary programming
coming in and saying
hang on you've pair bonded with this
other human for
x number of years and a baby hasn't
arrived
something's wrong something might be
wrong with them something might be wrong
with you
something might be wrong with the way
that you two interact but there is an
issue here
and we know jeans the genes know
if we get you to leave if we get you to
leave by making you no longer attracted
to them or loving
toward them that you can try with
someone else
and then maybe if the problem was them
you will have the problem fixed you will
be able to have children
because for all of evolutionary history
we've not had contraception
so if babies weren't happening presuming
that you were having sex i mean you
could have
a celibate relationship and still this
would come through
because the only reason that you are
here is because you are the the head of
the pin of an unbroken chain of
evolution and breeding that goes all the
way back four billion years
um and this is one man i see a lot of my
a lot of my buddies who are
very happily in a relationship with a
girl maybe
meet them at university or meet them in
their graduate job or something like
that
and they're still with them and they're
approaching 30 and they're like yeah
yeah yeah we're you know we're thinking
about
we're going to have kids maybe towards
certain i'm like dude you are
dicing with relationship death
here yeah i've seen and then the woman
leaves him and goes to someone else and
instantly gets pregnant i have seen that
a lot
in my practice um they split up and she
gets a new partner and is
instantly pregnant um and you kind of
wonder like okay
who's in the driver's seat in her head
right is it the brain
or or is it the womb which one's in the
driver's seat there
um all of us have a lot more animal in
us than we're willing to admit
all of us are a lot more neolithic than
we're willing to admit from ten thousand
years ago
um we we are rational beings but there's
more to us than that and we need to
recognize those instincts that exist
at at the very least so that we can
manage some of the problems that might
arise in our relationships if we aren't
aware that those things are creeping up
on us
adam lane smith ladies and gentlemen uh
where should people go they want to
check out your courses your books
oh yeah um well i'm i am adam
lanesmith.com where you'll find
everything i have psychology articles on
there i've got books i've written i've
got courses
on i am on gumroad if you find a lot of
courses i have a course called how to
get a girlfriend
it's one hour or more i think i keep
adding to it video course
teaching young men exactly
evolutionarily what women want
no matter what kind of woman she is or
where she comes from what does she want
from you and how can you get a
girlfriend and how
can you turn her into a wife and also
how to weed out the unhealthy partners
i teach that there my book that i've
written about attachment
it's called slaying your fear it's on
amazon
all kinds all the different geographical
amazon stores
um it's one of the number one anxiety
books on amazon for a period of time
brief period of time um but it walks
through what is attachment
um why does attachment matter what
happens when it's broken how do i fix it
and it walks a person through fixing
that attachment it's only about 100
pages
i think it's six dollars for the
audiobook and it's about two hours
it's short but it is punchy and right to
the point uh i highly recommend that for
anyone who has heard anything on this
podcast that thinks that may or may not
apply to them
i do always have to give a disclaimer
nothing i've said is healthcare advice
i'm not giving you therapy advice if you
have any issues that you feel are your
issues
please seek professional help don't
diagnose it through this course through
this
podcast that we're doing but i hope this
has been educational for people
dude you've crushed it uh i hope that
you continue adding to that thread so
i've got an excuse to bring you back on
soon
i have continued adding i was even
adding to that thread i think yesterday
dude it's linked in the show notes below
if you want to go and check out uh
adam's entire monstrous hundred tweet
plus threads now which is growing and
growing and growing
uh that'll be linked plus how to get a
girlfriend slaying your fear and
everything else dude thank you so much
thank you for having me
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few months
and don't forget to subscribe it makes
me very happy indeed
peace